okay let's have a look at the the sad
state of the Australian doll actually
look this up by the way this morning I
think it 72.4 when I looked it up which
is quite sad now this is a tricky
question by the way so if you've got two
famous if you got to this number down
the end their thumbs up to you this was
challenging I'm actually going to point
out another way of doing this later on a
second half of this double period but
let me walk you through the way that I
did this question before I what's this
you routed to 19 do you wrap it like
nearest I got any night without does not
oh sorry wait you mean you mean that how
many Australia does yeah sure that's
okay I'll talk about that a second that
answer would be fun okay let's just come
back to the weight or purchase all right
so the important part in this question
you can see is 72 cents for each
australian dollar right so this is a
question of ratios and rates right i
comparing two different things so you
can see what I've written down here I'm
literally writing the comparison between
these two themes and then I'm trying to
all of these all of these lines of
working here all I'm trying to do is get
10,000 over there on the right you see
where I'm aiming that's that's where I'm
headed and everything else is to do that
so what have I done prom let's just get
this out of the way what have I done
from the first line to the second leg
what's the difference I've converted the
right hand side the US currency into
dollars why would I do that yeah okay so
number one I've got to take me to tell
both sides kind of dollars but actually
more importantly it's because I want to
get to this number which is in dollars
they didn't say what is that incense
anyway that would be a million sense
then say give it to me in sense but the
72 us cents it's in a different unit so
that's why I convert ok now what have I
done what's this about why did I choose
to multiply by that
[Music]
I want to get to 10,000 right that's
what i want to receive back so in order
to turn 0.72 into 10,000 i'm going to
multiply by ten thousand that's the
number i want and then I / 0.72 okay you
can see I would get let's get a new
color here I'm gonna go cancel cancel
and that's what gives me the 10,000 that
I've got my final line do you see that
so this was challenging um all i have to
do on the left-hand side is just punch
that into my calculator and if you did
roundup I think that's fair because it
did say how many dollars though
generally speaking if you don't get
given any accuracy for a money question
obviously you go to go to sense and you
certainly want to go further than that
okay so like I said we will come back to
this question later on Oh in this double
it's a look at the last one now you guys
see I always kind of put more working
but you probably need ah here's my
answer down here the larger part I've
got as 40,000 okay now how do we logic
this out is it important idea here right
if you're dividing fortified right for
25 and I literally try and picture this
okay one of them get one of the people
gets four parts and the other person
gets five parts so if I add up all those
parts there are nine of them right and
also has the equal yeah so if there are
nine parts then that's where I get each
one of those little pieces has to be a
thousand dollars okay so clearly you
don't have to draw a diagram like this
but I hope you can see what I've done
it's like okay you slice it up and in
this guy gets four of them and this one
gets five that's what 425 means so
that's where this number five times
eight thousand comes from there are five
of these parts and each one of the
smaller bits is that size question India
there was it like a pretty right here
yeah yeah yeah that's a great question
okay well why don't we do it right now
okay so maybe you want to turn over turn
over and let's take that same amount
let's do this right now it's a great
question i'm so glad you asked what if i
want to split this up among more people
in different ways so I'm just going to
poop scuze me I'm just going to pick
this number because it's convenient all
right let's think about this suppose I
want to divide this up in 20 let's think
of a number of atop my head let's go one
to two to seven so here's the question
I'm just making this up because it was
it was something in the exercise of
similar so suppose I have three people
who I want to divide this up between and
this is the ratio right now even though
it looks a bit weird and this is where
it's at okay ratios are a little bit
different to fractures they're similar
but they're not exactly the same thing
that's why we treat them as a new kind
of idea yes yeah you can if I wanted to
buy two more than two people and I'm
going to use this ratio how do I go
about this now this is what's great
about this logic that I used before if I
think just like I did here right four or
five means that this person gets four
parts this person gets five parts or a
lot I've got to have nine patent oh yeah
four and five when you have a look down
here in this scenario uh how many plots
are they going to be in total and the
answer is 10 right 1 plus 2 plus 7
that's 10 in total ok so imagine 10
little pockets of money they're all
supposed to be equal so each i'm going
to call them each part each one of these
10 parts will be well how big will each
chunk be
seven hundred and twenty dollars right
where that comes from is is seventy-two
thousand dollars / 10 right that's
that's how many times I'm splitting it
up ok so now that I know how big each
parcel is how big each component is I
just make sure one of them gets 11 is
too ah so I ESRB panels dynamo hundred
okay so 7200 the first person gets one
of them the second person will get to
and the last person will get seven of
them right so I guess I'd say um i'm
going to write that the first person
receives one lot of the pot right these
are relatively easy numbers so i can say
the second person and so that i make it
clear where this is coming from right
I'm going to say to lots of that 7200
which I think we can come on we can do
this in our heads right on 14 for good
and two zeros um seven times okay I
don't know what that is but let's be a
little bit okay so yeah it is king um
seven lots are seven lots of this yeah
the same every packet is the same size
because someone tell me what that is
five
oh no I'm getting a lot of different
numbers here thank you okay and of
course one of the lovely things about
this when you when you stop and you
finish you say okay well apparently all
of these together they should comprise
that seventy two thousand dollars that i
began with right if you just don't like
exactly do it but if you look like all
about 50 this is about 20 yeah i'm in
the right ballpark thumbs up okay